moi je enfin c'est quelque chose qui ne
m'intéresse pas non c'est sans réponse
sans réponse le fn qui chasse sur des
territoires communiste pour les experts
cela n'a rien d'étonnant à c'est aussi
ça qui est visé c'est à dire
d'apparaître comme l'alternance en
milieu populaire où la seule alternative
à la gauche c'est le front national
puisque historiquement dans ces communes
l'ump où les partis qui l'ont constituée
ont toujours été réduit au rôle de
figuration à mitry-mory adrien des ports
espère au minimum cinq conseillers
municipaux
c'est vrai qu'à une note la semaine
dernière des services du ministère de
l'intérieur qui alerté sur une société
de plus en plus inflammable
une colère qui une colère qui s'exprime
non pas dans la rue mais dans les yeux
est-ce que petit à petit le front
national grignote ces voix populaire
mais écoutez il ya une situation du pays
qui est très inquiétante et c'est le
résultat de quoi de dix ans de politique
de droite qui ont multiplié le chômage
la précarité la pauvreté qui ont cassé
les solidarités qui les ont cassé
concrètement et qui les ont cassé dans
les têtes en développant des idées
d'égoïsme de repli de xénophobie
et puis maintenant une politique de
gauche est maintenant dans une politique
socialiste du gouvernement socialiste
qui au lieu de prendre le taureau par
les cornes et de faire ce qui était
promis c'est à dire on va s'attaquer au
pouvoir de la finance on va mieux
répartir les richesses
on va faire de la solidarité fait le
contraire donc il ya un moment où les
gens se disent alors il n'y a plus rien
à faire donc il faut à ce moment là que
des forces se lève et c'est ce que nous
faisons pour organiser justement cette
solidarité pour montrer qu'il est
possible de mener des pompiers m parce
que vous avez du mal à avoir des gens
dans la rue dans vos manifestations on a
l'impression que la classe politique les
syndicalistes sont impuissants
aujourd'hui qui coûtait un jour cesser
c'est le connaissent c'est ce qu est ce
qu on passe son temps à c'est ce qu'on
répète en permanence pour évacuer le
débat sur les responsabilités parce que
on peut voter demain matin un projet de
loi pour interdire les licenciements
boursiers
quand nous étions dans l'opposition
socialistes communistes et verts nous
l'avons voté ensemble pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne vote pas par manque de courage
politique
voilà tout simplement mais il existe
demain matin dès majorité à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat qui peuvent voter
ces lois là nous pouvons très bien au
lieu de faire la politique fiscale qu'on
est en train de faire on peut très bien
mettre les moyens pour aller chercher
les 50 milliards d'évasion fiscale elle
peut très bien contrôler les fonds
publics qu'on distribue aux entreprises
alors qu'ils s'en servent pour licencier
donc il ya aucune raison oiseaux je
conteste l'idée de l'impuissance
médication d'impuissance politique
contrairement à ce qu'on dit aux gens et
c'est une question qu'il faut avoir le
courage de s'attaquer au pouvoir de la
finance quand françois hollande disait
au bourget il y à un ennemi
eh bien il maintenant il faut le faire
du coup est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec jean luc mélenchon quand il dit que
finalement la politique du parti
socialiste est presque pire que celle de
l'ump
en tout cas c'est c'est pas une
politique de gauche là dessus moi je
peux aider dans certains domaines
elle est en train d'aggraver elle est en
train d'aggraver la situation voit avec
la réforme des retraites
on avait la réforme sarkozy on avait dit
on va la combattre
au lieu de la corriger on rallonge
encore les années de cotisation donc on
va voir si un cas structurel cette
réforme sur les retraites elle va
conduire à ce qu'on partira à nouveau
plus tard avec des retraites et des
pensions encore dégradée voilà le
résultat parce qu'avec plus en compte la
pénibilité par exemple dont elle elle
dit qu'elle prend en compte la
pénibilité et quand on passe aux
dispositifs concrets de prise en compte
de la pénibilité on est à des kilomètres
de ce que demande aux organisations
censure qu'à trois reprises qu'il y aura
un compte qu'elle est méritée
oui mais y'a des médias il y a des îles
y adhérer la seule chose nouvelle c'est
qu'on inscrit ce principe là dans la loi
mais pour ce qui est des dispositifs
concrets qui vont permettre d'accéder à
une véritable reconnaissance de la paix
habilité dans le projet de loi on est
très loin du compte et d'ailleurs si le
gouvernement veut rendre ça plus concret
il pourra très bien reprendre nos
amendements dans le débat qui démarre
lundi au cimic le voir parce que on va
pas manquer d'amender le projet sur
cette question et sur la question de la
jeunesse sur la question des retraites
des femmes et sur beaucoup d'autres
questions quelque 500 amendements
attendu de votre groupe effectivement
sur sur ce projet de loi retraites vous
confirmer qu'au sénat vous ne voterai ni
le projet de loi sur les retraites ni le
projet de loi ni la loi de finances ni
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale ne voteront pas le projet de loi
sur les retraites tel qu'il nous arrive
ça c'est clair et net
nous allons déposer vous dit à peu près
200 amendements nous avions un groupe ce
matin c'est à peu près ça eh bien nous
attendons que ces amendements soir
prince si on nous laisse ici comme à
l'assemblée nationale on nous retourne
tous ses amendements nous votre
rencontre et sur le budget nouveau trop
content pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'on nous propose encore de nous
enfoncer dans une logique budgétaire qui
n'améliore pas la situation du pays ne
permet pas de croissance ne résout pas
les inégalités et en plus ne résonneront
même pas les déficits seraient pas non
plus la première latino parce que nous
sommes toujours dans la même logique
toujours dans la même logique qui
continue à faire des cadeaux toujours ou
même et à ne pas résoudre les problèmes
les problèmes d'inégalités sociales note
yann lorence à s'abattre logique mais là
vous comprendrez que peut-être les
électeurs français soit un peu perdus
quand ils vous voient nouer des
alliances avec le parti socialiste même
si son cours des élections le loclois là
mais on s'est expliqué il est parce que
côte qui a une politique gouvernementale
comprenez qu'il refuse assez du coût des
partis politiques français chantent
oui mais attendez c'est tout ce qu'on
sait 290 justement c'est exactement le
contraire en ce qui nous concerne c'est
qu'on nous demande de nous enfermer dans
des postures politiques politiciennes a
priori et nous nous disons exactement au
contraire parce que nous mais parce que
notre boussole n'est pas celle que sur
laquelle vous m'interrogez en permanence
les alliances
moi ma boussole c est ce que ce qu'on
fait va être utile aux populations ou
pas et à paris csq rallu logement social
est-ce qu'on va lutter contre la
spéculation
est-ce qu'on va construire des crèches
pour répondre est-ce qu'on va est ce
qu'on va faire des transports publics et
c'était sur les vingt ans
sur les ca depuis 2001 oui absolument
l'équipe de bertrand delanoë et grâce
justement au travail des communistes
dans cette majorité a fait par exemple
de la construction de logement social
une de ses grandes priorités
je rappelle que quand de l'année delanoë
a gagné la ville en 2001 il y avait dans
le programme de delanoë l'idée de
construire 3000 logements sociaux par
eau
nous nous en propose ion plus à l'époque
et aujourd'hui on en construit cinq à
six mille par an grâce à la bataille que
nous avons menées et avec l'objectif qui
est retenu dans l'accord que nous ont
passé avec anne hidalgo
ce sera plus de 7000 logements sociaux
par an voilà ça c'est du concret et nous
c'est ce qui nous déterminent c'est pas
les alliances les postures et c'était
assez justement exactions étaient à
matignon alors là vous seriez derrière
si elle était à matignon pour prendre
cet exemple je pense que cette hypothèse
ne se ne se présente pas mais si elle ou
une autre et visait je change totalement
la politique du gouvernement actuel pour
en faire une autre mais on discuterait
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui quand
il s'agit de discuter la politique
gouvernementale
du côté de des dirigeants actuels du
parti socialiste pour le moment il ya
personne pour venir on va faire ça et
donc nous ne pouvons pas prêter la main
à cette politique qui va dans le mur
mais quand dans une commune il est
possible d'avancer dans ce sens là et
bien nous nous saisissons l'occasion
parce que précisément ce qui nous
intéresse c'est ce qui se passe pour les
jeunes arrivés par d'autres agriculteurs
sont mobilisés aujourd'hui contre le
projet d'écotaxe qui rentrera en vigueur
le 1er janvier 2014
est-ce qu'il faut la supprimer ou la
maintenir cette écotaxe les le problème
de cette écotaxe c'est qu'elle est elle
est une fois de plus elle et elle est
injuste elle qu'elle est conçue par ce
qu'elle va frapper des jo au niveau de
la consommation alors qu'en vérité il
faudrait prendre le problème de
l'écologie en amont parce qu'il faut une
politique écologique mais il faut sur
les transports apprécié de savoie risée
des madelinots ce parce qu'ils soient
moins polluants en l'occurrence vous dit
à des gens nous ne vous donnerons aucun
moyen de changer vos moyens de transport
de les renouveler parce que on sait que
les agriculteurs ont des problèmes de
revenus importants vous êtes obligés
de renouveler votre matériel et la seule
chose qu'on fait c'est qu'on vous taxe
halal
si on veut que ils utilisent des moyens
des moyens moins polluants et bien à ce
moment là on les aide à changer
d'équipement ont créé les conditions
pour qu'il change d'équipé aux finances
des nouveaux équipements et on aide les
agriculteurs à moderniser dans un sens
écologique leur matériel et leur mode de
production on s'attaque à la racine du
problème
là on le fait pas on dit qu'on fait ça
on fait rien du tout on les laisse dans
la même difficulté et on les taxe à la
sortie à plaisir c'est le sait mais même
les verts sont ne sont pas très contre
ces initiatives si défense initiative du
grenelle de l'écouter j'écoute ce que
disent les verts je discute beaucoup
avec eux je n'ai pas l'impression qu'ils
sautent de joie placé avait à coeur joie
devant la politique écologique du
gouvernement
d'accord ça dans mon taxi ça n'arrête
pas de dire que cette politique
écologique n'est pas mais ce n'est pas
ta n'est pas il pose aussi des
conditions sur les coûts traces sur le
scandale de l'espionnage des services
secrets américains vers l'europe
notamment la france vous demander à ce
que la france sorte de l'otan mais ce
que voulait aussi qu'on mettre fin à
toute coordination coopération de lutte
contre le terrorisme mais écoutez
quelques ailes et quel est le rapport
quel rapport est ce que vous payez que
son esprit autre pour les français qui
utilisent les communications des
communications téléphoniques qu'on va
lutter contre le terrorisme très sérieux
des rapports entre la france et les
états unis
surtout que cette affaire n'est pas la
première on en est déjà au trot
quatrième incident lourd quand même je
parle même pas de l'arrêt de l'avion des
veaux morales et et autres autre
incident diplomatique
jusqu'à quand va se faire humilier par
un pays qui dit non à droite surveiller
tout le monde on fait ce qu'on veut
personne n'a le droit de nous demander
des comptes et puis on continue
d'accepter ça et on accepte de
s'intégrer dans le commandement
militaire intégré de l'otan sous
responsabilité des américains et on n'a
pas notre mot à dire
moi j'ai connu même à droite quand même
des dirigeants politiques qu avait un
peu plus de dignité pour faire respecter
la parole de la force et rage en
différents mettre en cause notamment les
accords de libre échange
oui il faut
seulement il faut remettre en cause ce
qui existe mais il faut surtout pas
aller vers ce qu'on nous propose en
europe
le pacte transatlantique le traité du
grand marché transatlantique qui
préconise de libéraliser tous les
échanges et qui va ouvrir en fait nos
marchés aux états unis sans aucune sans
aucune contrepartie d'alliance de
dignité demandez vous à laon la démo
l'état mais il ya un échange vif du
temps avec barack obama essayé sa
réprobation que c'est la mauvaise est la
moindre des choses quand même et c'est
l'ordre des choses mais puisque ont
commencé la discussion sur le temps je
pense que nous devrions développer une
politique de la france plus indépendante
et qui n'attendent pas le feu vert des
états unis pour décider ce qu'elle fait
dans telle ou telle région question oui
oh non c'est vrai vous vous parlez plus
du tout avec jean luc mélenchon qui cet
été vous n'avez pas répondu de s'arrêter
on comprenait les images si j'avais
publié même à la fête de l'humanité on a
à plusieurs reprises
on s'est croisé ensemble a fait de
manger de croiser si vous parlez on a
compris qu'un rendez vous était prévu au
début du 20 novembre le 3 ou 4 le 4
novembre pour discuter sur les élections
européennes
bonsoir à tous